roger karoutchi la sénateure les
républicains à des hauts-de-seine
roger karoutchi bonjour merci d'être en
direct avec nous sur rt france alors un
second tour des municipales dans un
contexte inédit avec des stratégies
électorales nouvelles on le disait ce
contexte inédit avec aussi des cris de
colère a entendu ces derniers jours
quel impact peut-il avoir sur les
électeurs selon vous pour ce second tour
des municipales y aura forcément un
certain nombre de d'éléments qui vont
jouer
premier point est ce que la crise
sanitaire
ses effets même si aujourd'hui on dit
que bien entendu la pandémie régresse
est-ce que encore un certain nombre
d'électeurs notamment parmi nos
électeurs d'un certain âge vont aller
voter vont avoir comprendre la décision
d'aller voter je rapelle que au 1er tour
du 15 mars
35% des électeurs de plus de 65 ans ne
sont pas allés voter 35% en plus de la
moyenne normale ce qui veut dire que
beaucoup d'électeurs âgés n'étaient pas
allés voter
on va voir ce que ça donne cette fois ci
deuxième élément la situation nationale
est catastrophique
chacun en est conscient l'autorité de
l'état n'est plus qu'un vain mot
le hiatus pour ne pas dire la cassure
entre le gouvernement et l'ensemble des
forces de sécurité mais au delà des
forces de sécurité et l'ensemble de ceux
qui considèrent qu'il faut de l'ordre
public républicaine dorit l'aide de
l'état pour assurer la paix sociale
ça va forcément avoir des conséquences
sur le vote des uns ou des autres
ensuite la campagne est même bien sûr
elle est totalement différente des
campagnes classiques
on ne peut pas faire deux réunions
publiques mais là je me permets
d'attirer juste l'attention du ministre
de l'intérieur
donc il est interdit de faire des
réunions publiques mais visiblement on
peut faire des manifestations de
plusieurs milliers de personnes à
l'extérieur sans la moindre contrainte
de distanciation social qui est une
aberration mais c'est comme ça y a pas
de réunion publique
c'est une campagne essentiellement de
proximité
par définition se promène avec masque
sur dans la rue c'est parce qu'elle est
plus facile pour pour être en contact
électorale et puis c'est une campagne
plutôt de pointage de lettres ou de e 2
e mail c'est à dire que c'est une
campagne plus internet ou médiatique
mais c'est pas c'est pas une campagne
classique de proximité d'aller faire des
réunions d'appartement dériot public ou
de faire les escaliers ça par définition
c'est totalement écartée en ce moment
alors chez les républicains
quels sont les enjeux de ce second tour
des municipales et dans quel état
d'esprit abordez-vous cette campagne
écoutez comme toujours quand les choses
deviennent plus politiques puisque les
sur les 5000 communes ce sont
essentiellement des communes
relativement importante les petites
communes pour la plupart ont été réglées
dès le premier tour sur avec des trente
mille communes côté agréé dès le 15 mars
donc c'est n'a pas eu plus politique que
la campagne globale du premier tour
quand même plus politique ça veut dire
que forcément les éléments nationaux
gestion de la crise pandémique gestion
économique crise sociale crise
économique chômage qui explose tout ça
c'est le contexte de la campagne
ça veut dire que d'un côté nous
républicain dans l'opposition au
gouvernement
nous avons des éléments de reproche à
faire au gouvernement qui peuvent
évidemment jouer sur les listes locales
qui soutiennent le gouvernement
ils sont en marche les stagiaires etc et
puis nous avons nous affaire
l'autre sens si je puis dire à une
opposition de gauche qui sert vitaliser
qui s'est remobilisé donc il ya un
certain nombre de villes je pense à
marseille toulouse à bordeaux où nous
avons le vrai challenge
alors que nous avons les sortants
d'avoir des listes de gauche qui
pourrait nous déstabiliser donc là une
campagne plus forte sur le risque que
pourrait représenter les extrémistes de
gauche et à paris par exemple évidemment
ce n'est pas le cas à paris c est ce que
vous voulez une ville plus propre est ce
que vous voulez une ville plus sur ce
que voulaient une ville plus équilibré
bon
partir du moment où on considère qu
agnès buzyn n'a plus aucune chance
évidemment il faut recentrer les
bulletins sur incident à des types de
manière à ce que elle puisse être en
position de l'emporter et rosé quant aux
chiffres ville plus plus étonnante même
pour nos par exemple la métropole de
lyon où après l'accord passé avec
l'ancien ministre de l'intérieur
gérard collomb et bien alors que là nous
n'avions théoriquement pas de ses
chances de l'emporter
nous retrouvons de vraies chances de
gagner avec un partage des compétences
entre la ville de lyon et la métropole
de lyon pour nous c'est extrêmement
simple
au premier tour le 15 mars 55% des
communes qui ont donné un maire dès le
premier tour sont revenus vers les
républicains ou leurs proches seulement
5% vers en marche 5 % fois en marche ou
deuxième tôt c'est évidemment plus
compliqué nous n'avons que cinq mille
communes mais qui représente près de 30%
des électeurs
donc nous attendons le 28 en espérant la
même vague que le 15 mars
nous partons avec l'avantagé d'avoir
beaucoup de sortants ont bien fait leur
job
nous partons avec l' avantage si je puis
dire l'ambroisie dans la république qui
évidemment n'est plus aussi bien crédité
dans l'opinion publique qu'il pouvait
l'être il ya un an 2 donc équilibres
politiques bonne gestion locale bonne
implantation nous espérons naturellement
conserver nos villes en emporter de
nouvelles je pense à metz pourquoi pas
paris pourquoi pas d'autres qui
pourraient revenir dans l'escarcelle des
républicains alors vous étés rucci vous
vous parlez d'une remobilisation de la
gauche dans certaines communes comment
est ce que vous vous l'art comprenez
cette remobilisation de la gauche elle
est logique d'abord parce que comme
souvent quand on nous dit les partis
classiques ses morts et ses terrasses et
de nouveaux mondes - je n'y crois guère
j'en ai vu des batailles perdues ou
gagnées
on nous expliquait que tout allait être
changée et nouveau puis un arm 2 après
les espèces d'habitude électorale se
reprenait donc là moi j'ai jamais
considéré que la gauche avait disparu il
a six listes
le l'échec de la politique
gouvernementale
les difficultés sociales les difficultés
économiques
la remontée du chômage ou pour un
certain nombre de gens sa robe
mobilisent en faveur de la gauche ou en
faveur des républicains lorsque nous
sommes dans la mobilisation et nous
sommes prêts à avancer mais c'est une
évidence que la situation nationale est
telle que les listes en mars ont été
pulvérisés oprag et or à mon avis ne
feront pas carrière au deuxième tour et
ce sont les listes d'opposition donc
soit de droite pour les républicains
lorsque nous ajoutons la sécurité
l'ordre public
l'autorité de l'état ou bien
l'opposition de gauche lorsqu'elle joue
énormément sur la situation sociale
dramatique
eh bien ce sont évidemment des pôles
d'intérêts qui attire beaucoup les
électeurs merci beaucoup roger karoutchi
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes sénateur les
républicains des hauts-de-seine